hi I'm Chopra and I work at Wolfram and
I'm gonna present computational taxonomy
in biology it's one of my hobbies to
identify a species so I'm gonna use
Wolfram language to identify several
species with images with alius and also
to show about the power of well from
knowledge base
so my name is jefra um my parents in
physics but I'm gonna talk about biology
today since the kids I was a kid I
really like it to explore the outside
world and look for fossils species and
now last year I started to to identify a
species using the one app called a
naturalist so I became interested in
pulling all that data I was collecting
from the outside world into Wolfram
language so I'm gonna try to give a talk
on taxonomy even if I'm not an expert an
expert and give you some hints on what
is possible with a Wolfram language and
biodiversity data so yeah it's the
definition of taxonomy basically is that
the way biologists have classified
biological organism and just I will give
you some brief story on it I think it's
too small to see it here this timeline
plot is Aristotle was one of the
founders on the systems to classify
organism and one of his students was
more focus on plants and then there was
like a gray area on on the middle age
and finally that kind of the father of
of the modern taxonomy is the Swedish
Carlos Lynn Lynn Reno's I don't know if
I pronounced correctly because he was
he's a Swedish name name and I think I
will maybe give you I don't know if how
many of you didn't know that there was
like one Beetle run back called crucial
in Mathematica so probably the first
historically discovered by her all at
1875
and is the detection in Maghreb of the
one caught in that array using the
building knowledge from species in both
from language I think that's for just
that the start of the theory and here
I'm just gonna keep topic of Halloween
again and show what's possible on
taxonomy of Pam kinks with the Wolfram
language and yeah there's like a lot of
ways of visualizing the taxonomy of the
different species of pumpkins at least
the ones in in the US and there's even
possible to get the data from the USDA
and have such like a cool map on the
different pumpkin species that you can
find in in the US since like a time ago
I was submitting the my first function
in the warm function repository it's
called a taxon taxonomic nearest and
here one can explore and learn a bit
more about taxonomy for example I did
not know that the cucumber and a
watermelon is closer to a pumpkin than
an eggplant
and that's from last year
internal one-liner competition and
basically I'm creating an image collage
of the species endangered species around
over the globe and it's kind of really
amazing that with a welcomed language
you can compact all that information in
just one line and then you can do also
things like give me all the mammals that
wait more than 10 kilograms and then
give me a community graph on these
animals based on the taxonomy and and
then each vertex is also has a size
depending on on the size of animal or in
this case the weight all right
I think it's a it's too heavy I haven't
shared a notebook yet because it's 100
something megabytes it might crash but
that's that's what hopefully it is
crashing
so what whatever you want to include
like import some data that is not
already like in the Wolfram knowledge
base so nowadays there are like several
international platforms for 4 species
and infrared data and some of them are
are traded to the genomics of other
species some of them are like more like
the the occurrences like the GBI f:e all
is also having a lot of information on
morphology and different traits of a
species its encyclopedia of life and I
think for example warfare mafias using
one one list of species from catalogue
of life and nowadays there's like a kind
of a big mess on all these list of
species names because they have like all
these kind of institutions have
different lists and whenever one biology
is discovering new species or changing
name of exact in the taxon is not
automatically change on the other
databases so there's like some like many
many inconsistencies and under like
there is a new international project
called catalogue of life plus that tries
to solve this problem
I'm not going to talk about it because
it's still not finished but there is
like a github link on that project so
now I will focus on on importing the
data from from my naturalist it's the
app that I have been using since last
January I think and identified more than
800 species during that time
and so if you haven't downloaded the app
you can download in your phone it's free
and make a user account and you will you
will be able to then do some search
queries and a specific for example and
that you want information about crucial
in a mathematically vital and see all
the observations that people have done
in or around the globe so I think they
have just like something back yeah just
to give an example of all possible
properties that you can have in this and
such a dataset from a naturalist
I'm not going to go through all of them
and here I'm going just like focus on on
on geolocation and image URLs and I will
start with spiders because today is
Halloween so I think I found like around
75 spider spirals since last year around
the planet and this is a kind of I call
it the emoji spider
it has like a smile a smiley face you
know if you can see it it's an herbed
web spider from Dominican Republic so
it's one you have this dataset which we
can just to show that it's really easy
to to imported it asset using semantic
import and you get a really nice data
set format so then it's quite trivial to
do like things like date histogram on
all the observation of spiders through
the last year I think that there was
like a gap he made I don't know why but
this was summer school and some
and yeah also like things like timeline
plot with tooltip or labels of the
images I think this is like the first
days during the summer school some of
the people here helped me to find some
of the spiders jumping spiders and then
finally let's go to Geographics and
obviously my my hometown is near Girona
so I plotted all the different species
that have been finding during the last
summer I guess and but I will go back to
the Dominican Republic ones because
they're like said of them that I haven't
been able to in defi yet and it might be
like new species of spiders and here
like show also have to import the images
from the image URL and have like a
tooltip and see where the tarantulas are
and a jumping spider as well and I think
some of these are like unidentified yet
so we have if you are a spell expert you
can come to me and help me define them
so let's get closer look what Pico
Duarte this is the highest mountain in
the Caribbean and yeah you can also use
different geo backgrounds like relief
map to get a better picture of of the
hiking I was doing and the spires in the
different elevations of the mountain I
think this is a jumping spider eating a
fly alright and I think it's not really
visible but here what what I wanted to
do is also to show that you can really
get a really nice list plot 3d of the of
the mountain itself and I think it's it
could be useful for for identifying
where the spiders live in which side of
the mountain according to the sand for
example
so they're like a lot of possibilities
using all that well from language
version IDs
okay have to convert the scientific name
into a entity already existing in the
Wolfram language using interpreter for
example it's a good way there are
certain species that are not in the
database yet hopefully soon we can
include all the all the species that are
are missing as entities and yeah and
some of them are have like different
names that they exist but for example
the genus change it over time and it's
not there anymore
yeah more spiders for Halloween and you
can see that like some of them were like
not really
interpreted or not in the system yet all
right so let's go to another platform
that I have been using for getting more
information on species it's the global
biodiversity information facility it's
not an app like AI naturalist it's more
like a organization that collects data
from different situations included data
from an actual list and here you just
have to log in and create an account
it's a it's for free and then you are
able to also to download a lot of data
from certain species or geographic
locations and have likes in this case
I'm just going to focus on one of the
nudibranch that I was finding
historically nimbus fauna it's called
sea goddess need another branch fairly
mario picture and i'm showing how to
also like from the urls from this data
database of observations to get to
import the image and also to import the
data set on occurrences which is
can give you a list of the properties
there are similar to the naturals
properties but I think in in gif there
are like many more properties like
institution IDE and in some cases they
have like DNA as well but I'm not I'm
gonna just focus on on geo locations
dates and species name are institutions
in the follow me for example from the
United States National Museum there like
several fairly Mari
Victor this Cieslak on Cali for I know
this is Florida spring under same I can
do the same for form a heater MC I think
it's quite small and plot the different
geo markers with different chords
depending on on the the institution I
think here the green ones are from I
naturalist and here's from a region of
Spain like Valencia I think it's like a
university diving club over there the
one I found is it's it's umber swords
should be like here but it's still not
the data's are still not in energy in
the GBI F it's only in I naturalist on
global map so these species live all
over the the globe
almost
and just to compare that like I could
get my image from the latest data set
from a naturalist from the same species
that's my my photo and the water looks
like a Pokemon like a Pikachu all right
and now I will start discussing about
what platform is good for importing data
about ecosystems like a food network of
different species of animals or
interactions between parasites or
animals with animals in this case I'm
gonna use the data from global biotic
interactions and it was not that trivial
to work with it because it's a 9g avails
9 gigabytes document and you can get a
lot of relationships between different
species so here I'm just going to give
you the URLs and a hint how to start
working with it I haven't worked much I
just have like function that which works
somehow to to create such like graph of
relationships between different species
and then I'm just showing a like a toy
example on on a graph a food a food web
with different species and then perform
on top of it some some graph functions
like for example to use the pinch the
PageRank centrality to get the most
important note on the graph and which
species could disappear yeah I think
here I didn't know what was a Tod towhee
so I check it that it's it's one of the
one of these birds and I think to hit I
realize that these it's called out
louse right it's not really eating some
flour so this is really a toy example
should be eating blood sucking black
from from other animals all right so I
will start now the machine learning
section tools for identifying these
animals based on this data first I will
start with this simple case using
imaging buffet if it works perfect if
not you have to go to more sophisticated
methods like narrow networks and train
your own neural networks with your data
in this case I guess it's it's kind of a
bit of cheating here because I'm using
the image from the from world forum and
then I'm trying to identify with
indentify the same image so probably
it's already like in it was used for
training it so it really gets that it's
it's a bald eagle in this case so there
like some limitations is also like a
bald eagle but flying looks like more
culture and it it thinks that that's a
bulge here and probably but still I
guess it's a bird of prey okay so I'm
going to show you some example on
training your neural networks with
images that's or if you were in in in
some of the sessions from machine
learning team this example already
existed it's like three different kind
of mushrooms and then train it on on
this data and this is like a toy example
but you could also import data from
three different species and identify it
so
also interesting neural network that
exists already in the neural network
repository it's the I will not pronounce
all these letters but there's like a
link here and it's it's helping to kind
of localized and put in a box is
different any month for objects in the
image so in this case I'm gonna show one
easy example of there's like two birds
two different species of birds on one
orange on a branch and then using some
tweaks on it I'm able to kind of crop
the different birds from the image and
then I can upload in this case I would
be able to plot it for two to my natural
his account and get a new species
without me doing the the whole process
of cropping the different species and
then copying pasted and so that was like
an example that it only gets one of the
species are naturalized so and here I
think I will try to finish with a cool
example on are these samples last Sunday
I was working around the area and and I
I heard an owl and I was recording with
my iPhone this owl so I tried to
discover what was a species of this hour
and I don't know if there's like enough
sound here but let's try it no it's not
going to work but anyway it's an owl
singing you can use identify on animals
it says it's a bird at least
then you campers from a spectrogram with
Mal frequencies and then also do some
filtering to get a clear a clear sound
of the of the our sound syncing I think
it was in front of the the football the
football stadium so then I look at in a
naturalist would are like the the main
species in this area of owls and it
turns out that the two most common owls
are the great horned owl and the the
buret owl I saw her a towel in in during
the warm summer school in Boston but I
haven't heard need of them singing so I
didn't know which was which one was it
and I think this is too small so
basically I'm gonna create two classes
and import all the audios that I could I
could find in a naturalist and then
train a neural network on audio perform
a feature space plot to see if it's
going to be successful from from this
case it doesn't seem that it's that
trivial that it will perform the job but
at the end I was training it and
successfully identified that it was boo
boo boo gene Nia knows that it's like
the great Hornet owl and actually I got
the confirmation by some biologists in
there I noticed that that that was the
case that's just to showcase an example
yeah here there's like some some links
to other I think some links to other
resources for audios not just I
naturally so you can also get obvious
from the Cornell Lab of Ornithology
Shannon canto it's also like a platform
I was using back in 2015 during my
summer school project with the help of
ricardo porting birds and then there is
also the dis built-in function called
web audio search it was not really
working well for for such species but it
worked well for other animals more
common ones and then finally oops i
think time is over
so should i try to finish that part it's
the last one basically it's about geo
visualizations importing in this case
all the albums observe but in in in the
state of illinois this is really small
dots but and then comparing i was
curious about if there was like some
correlation on our observations and all
the wind farms in the state of Illinois
but I think it's there's not such a
clear correlation these are like the
density at geo smooth histogram on the
distribution of wind wind farms I was
getting the idea from from Geographics
talk from him an oil versus and he's
plotting the the two days wind direction
I did not use the snow but there's like
kind of a mild correlation but I think
people where people live there like more
observations because this is Chicago and
I don't believe that there are like many
more hours in Chicago City than in other
regions of Illinois
so yeah I will just close my talk with
the future work its need to be done
maybe to endure it I naturally API into
the Wolfram language will be like super
useful to get easily the data it's quite
easy now to get the data but you have to
go to the entries platform download the
CSV file and then use semantic import
and then maybe also the global biotic
interactions is quite interesting to see
all the networks interactions between
species also for biodiversity studies
and calculating value by diversity
indices may be integrating some bio
habitats into Geographics I don't know
if it already exists that or there is a
plan for incorporating such data on
different biomes like tundra or desert
and all these and finally I want to
thank everyone who was also helping me
to find species during warm summer
school and yeah raccoons do exist found
one last summer school Timothy and and
yeah thank you very much
I'm going to try to upload the notebook
but it right now it's like to be so
that's like to have to take some data
out but yeah feel free to contact me or
yeah do you have some question just yeah
but it's I'm a bit over for example each
user has their rights to to put what's
the license that they are sharing the
photos for example by default I was not
sharing with CC like Creative Commons or
or like there is a license that I'm
actually is allowed to share this
information if they cite all the data
that is coming from the different users
always that at the end you are they
sharing also the the observation so it
always pinpoints to the real user who
was identifying that that animal but I
cheated my my pre settings on the
observations and now my reader is it's
going to be shared with this other
platform the GBI F all that there's like
I think I have like a an image that I
can show about the different licenses
this is I think it's AI naturalist I can
do it bigger so in this case I think I'm
using the third one you can just no
copyright and someone can make money
after few pictures and I think the one
by default it's it's this one
attribution non-commercial share-alike
so yeah I encourage you to open a new
insurance account if you don't have it
and a star
collecting new data that can be then
imported to workroom and there was like
some other question I think but one more
question yeah because it's Halloween
actually no actually have data from all
kind of animals in the Dominican
Republic for example I saw a humpback
whale as well it's there in the data but
today I thought that just I would just
focus on spiders because it's it's
Halloween
also because I have some when I was 17 I
was collecting spiders from a national
park and I found one new species for
Spain
I mean first night was not discovered
there's there's no I could not give a
name to that spiders and yeah and there
are several at least two spiders called
something mathematica so I would be
happy to look for them twice in
Australia and the other I don't know
where is it so I don't know it's I
should put at the end like looking for a
sponsor
[Applause]